if you're watching tonight you are aware
of the threats we face in these united
states you know that there's a war on
the american way of life where anyone
who believes in simple truths like faith
or freedom or the flag or the fact that
george washington and thomas jefferson
and teddy roosevelt are good that's
people like you are the enemy as abraham
lincoln said shall we expect some
transatlantic military giant to step the
ocean and crush us at a blow
never all the armies of europe asia and
africa combined with all the treasure of
their earth in their military chest with
a bonaparte for a commander could not by
force take a drink from the ohio or make
a track on the blue ridge in a trial of
a thousand years
if danger ever reach us it must spring
up amongst us it cannot come from abroad
if destruction be our lot we must
ourselves be its author and finisher as
a nation of free men we must live
through all time or die by suicide
he was just 28 years old when he said
this but as in all things the great
emancipator saw the truth
death by suicide was the catastrophe
facing the republic then and it is sadly
the same today
the enemies of the american way seek to
stoke our divisions schisms and
sicknesses in pursuit of their own
agenda they use all the tools at their
disposal money manipulation and even
open propaganda to weaken our country in
every way
but those urging us toward national
suicide don't just come from within they
are backed from abroad and no foreign
power is a better friend ally and master
of this effort to drive america to
suicide than the communist party of
china
the ccp is actively engaged in an effort
to undermine our american way of life
its reach extends into our businesses
our sports our education our press and
our government we shouldn't be surprised
by this they're communists after all
subversion is what they do and they get
bored subjugating their own people but
china is doing this with the active
cooperation of our fellow americans
their partners in this project aren't
just malevolent spies manipulating
doofus california congressman it's none
other than our own cultural business and
academic elites who they have bought and
paid for a thousand times over
our elites now operate hand in glove
with the communist party of china doing
its bidding even when it harms the
freedoms and rights that are the
birthright of every american we see it
all the time
we see it when american movie stars like
john cena issue cringing apologies at
communist party orders we see it when
lebron james and the nba bend over
backwards to avoid ever offending the
chinese communists even when fans
support the chinese people we see it
when american companies like apple
eagerly eagerly cooperate with
communists to create an internet better
designed to suppress human freedom
we see it when american universities
tolerate the existence of communist
controlled networks to suppress free
speech on campus we see it when
amazon.com wrapped by none other than
barack obama press flak j carney
partners with communist enforcers to
take down negative reviews of the
chinese dictator's books
we see it when the walt disney company
in the credits to its 2020 live-action
flop mulan publicly thanked communist
chinese security organs in xinjiang the
same people engineering a literal
genocide of uyghurs
we see it when intel issues a craven
cringing apology to the communist party
of china for adhering to american
sanctions we see it when top scientists
at top universities turn out to have
been doing the bidding of the ccp for
years hiding their payoffs in their
luggage
we see it when biden administration
bureaucrats panic over a map showing
taiwan a different color from china and
cut the video of a taiwanese speaker at
their fraudulent summit for democracy
these aren't abstract matters of
national standing or great power
credibility the communist party of china
is reaching directly into the fabric of
american life these are the sports you
watch the products you buy the companies
where you work the movies you stream and
the schools and colleges where your
children learn
in 2021 there was one us-based major
institution willing to stand up to the
ccp the women's tennis association
faced with the obvious
quasi-imprisonment of a chinese tennis
player who credibly accused a senior
communist official of sexual assault the
wta refused the cowardice of every other
relevant sporting body on the planet and
suspended its chinese operations they
lost out on huge revenue and growth
opportunities why
because there was something the
communists could not buy from them
decency dignity and the truth
i ask you tonight
who will stand against the communist
party of china
not our government not our elites not
our tech firms not our universities not
our celebrities not our entrepreneurial
geniuses or our titans of industry
the women's tennis association did god
bless them for it but they aren't enough
are you getting it yet
do you see how the nexus between our
corrupt elites at home and the communist
party of china abroad makes them
effectively the same threat do you see
that fighting one means fighting them
both
consider why does the communist party of
china care so much about subverting and
ending american freedom partly it's
plain power politics if you're schooled
in the politics of the
high you believe in a zero-sum world
your loss is my gain but it's something
more than that
mostly they do it because the communist
party of china believes it is locked in
the life or death struggle with the
united states and unlike us it acts
accordingly
nearly a decade ago the communist
leadership gathered to discuss the world
situation and china's place in it the
result of this particular meeting was a
secret circular a communique on the
current state of the ideological sphere
it is better known these days simply as
document number nine
document number nine had one purpose and
one purpose only to let the 90 million
members of the communist party of china
know who the enemy is
here according to the ccp's general
office are the enemy's weapons
western constitutional democracy western
freedom democracy and human rights civil
society individual rights freedom of the
press the separation of powers the
multi-party system general elections
independent judiciaries and nationalized
armies
all these things according to document
number nine are mortal threats to
communist rule and you know
they're right
the principles and institutions that
undergird america are mortal threats to
communist rule and to the rule of
tyranny everywhere they've always
understood this sometimes better than we
have
but this is also a list of threats to
something else it's a list of threats to
the rule of our own elites our own
corrupt titans our own complacent
political class
are you awake
do you see how the threat at home and
the threat abroad are one and the same
common enemies make common cause and
they depend on our divisions to rule
the prescriptions at the end of document
number nine call for more fanatical
control by the party over life and
discourse but then there is this we in
the communist party of china must
reinforce our management of all types
and levels of propaganda on the cultural
front perfect and carry out related
administrative systems and allow
absolutely no opportunity or outlets for
incorrect thinking or viewpoints to
spread
what we know now that we didn't quite
grasp in 2013 when document number nine
was issued is that this wasn't just an
imperative within china the ccp intended
then and now to control incorrect
thinking or viewpoints as it defines
them in america too
and shameful as it is
they found plenty of american partners
who feel exactly the same way
this is the biggest threat facing
america today
not russia not islamic terrorism not
even the very real threats on our
southern border this external threat is
existential because it is amplified by
its alliance with the major internal
threat facing america the malign union
of leftist authoritarian elites who seek
to corrode this country from within
there are some even some conservatives
who believe the internal threats we face
are so great we cannot hope to win this
fight
they argue we must focus on ourselves
that our elites and leadership are too
incompetent to contend with communist
china
i get it
i've been sounding the alarm on our
feckless and incompetent military elites
for years but the truth they fail to
understand is that in the case of
communist china the internal and
external threat are one and the same
the fight against our corrupt
surrender-minded elites in academia in
government in business in sports in
media and beyond
is inseparable from the fight against a
communist chinese leviathan that funds
abets directs and encourages them the
monolithic union of american and
communist chinese interests and money
that has dominated our national life for
the past generation must end
american firms that cooperate with
communist chinese repression must suffer
penalties including criminal ones if
need be american firms that outsource
supply chains and manufacturing to
communist china must move to friendly
countries or better yet bring them back
home
american sports and film stars who
kowtow to communist demands should
suffer public shame american
universities must cease all cooperation
with communist controlled institutions
have zero tolerance for communist
controlled networks and informers on
their campuses and ideally should not be
educating prc citizens at all
that american government bureaucracies
should be compelled to stop funding and
cooperating with communist bureaucracies
and institutions the wuhan institute of
virology sounds like a good place to
start
do these things or even threaten them
and the cry goes up from the elites
you'll hurt american jobs and prosperity
if you cut off communist china
this is the suicide note lincoln
denounced we should not have to accept
the dominance of communist china as the
price tag for our american way of life
it is also a lie
the united states had virtually no trade
with mainland china from 1949 clear
through into the 1990s yet we managed to
construct the world's highest standard
of living without them
so
let's do it again for all that we have
been and meant we cannot look away from
this fight
the enemy is here now
he commands the heights of hollywood
silicon valley and wall street he is
poisoning our people in body and mind he
may put jeff bezos over his knee to
demand only five star reviews but he
does not command us
we are americans we are wide awake and
we are ready to fight for our schools
for our governance for our culture
the future does not belong to you and
neither do we
our minds are free and they are not for
sale hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else